yeah hello and welcome to our Monday
night's live show I hope everything
works out right because you have a
couple of changes today you know you
probably don't see it oh I see the ball
is not I did not go for the wooden
layout why is that it's a little bit
strange let me fix that right away okay
so yeah we have some changes here we
have that the time is a little bit weird
because of the it's a usual time game
started in um in Europe but for the US
guys it's so a bit different
so um because of the time change we had
the time change and in Europe I this one
of those f3 guys you have the line that
I don't understand
check I never really see what white
players want to achieve with that it
always looks terrible to me but it is it
is what it is that is plate yeah and I
keep forgetting why and how exactly it
is plate yeah and um there are also some
slight changes let's say in YouTube like
under the hood you don't see it ready
but they have been some some changes
technically so I hope everything works
alright also I had some changes in my
office so I had to rearrange the green
screen it doesn't really don't think
it's it's better so
yeah anyway the whole desk set up that
has a little bit different because today
I tried to install a new monitor here
and no it didn't work out for me yeah I
got the new model 2 delivered and it was
delivered yeah broken basically I don't
remember exactly how that line works
really I have forgotten it
it's based on some tactics you know like
Chucky should be are these kind of
things but still never understand what
the real point is because White has no
development and why does that work in
the first place
ok so um but I think I'm taking us
simply simply to check this off ok I
cannot go Queen d7 yeah I think he and
particular white is quite okay probably
I mean I don't think I'm worse but I
didn't exactly refute what he did
especially losing castling rights is not
that fantastic
yeah I kinda have to get back into the
5-minute rhythm I played something some
bullets earlier to kill time and yeah
that's not a really great preparation
sometimes so how do we do this yeah I
can take this and I can't do that
get the pawn back I mean Queen before
doesn't look particularly frightening I
have night back at a 95 yeah that looks
a little bit Audion for me Queen B 6s
maybe a move him Queen b6 checking e3
this is probably trading I don't know I
mean he's got to be pawn but I don't
think this is a big deal maybe a maybe
I'm not really all that well-organized
just castle maybe that's a little bit
that's a little bit awkward
rook c1 for Roxy six and so on maybe I
have at least have to be precisely in
this position rook to e7 okay yeah I
guess I guess I have to do this yeah
this is pretty it's not so easy now for
him I'm on this I'm on the king and
let's see what he does
I have some tricks now removing the
night he cannot so easily unpin it s D 2
and F 2 are covered or I will seem
yeah I was thinking that doesn't work I
thought I'd just do this hmm he cannot
take do tonight c5 check and I'm an
exchange up at the end the rook is like
here
okay so what's that night c5 rooks III
it's kind of unfair that this would work
maybe have to go somewhere else here
maybe now I'm threatened to threatening
to take twice only three and then Knight
c4 between that could work yeah I'm not
trapping my own night no I don't think
so
and this is awkward for him man now this
is not easier oh why does that work
hmmm somehow it looks like it shouldn't
but it does
good defensive move I guess
on the upside and I'm quite up one time
that's good check it is not exactly
increasing his speed let's activate this
yeah I'm not happy how this unfolded
definitely not not great but I've had
tons of games like that
the other way around yeah simply being
being a bit better and then check and
then I'm struggling with chat home check
night before now night takes before the
check check
white resigned
yeah I think with the time he was in
trouble in some way I don't know I don't
think the b-pawn is a big factor like at
the end at least I'm so close to that it
shouldn't be shouldn't be a big thing
okay let's go for a new game
yeah the outside permit I'm reasonably
close to it so I don't think it's it's a
huge factor you have to cause some
became started
how did hog I get that bigger rating
it's strange and of course he's playing
the same opening as usual
I know I kind of I would add one point
simply do something else and because he
it's just not not good but he keeps
playing it him he really really really
must be convinced there that that it is
that it is a good thing
I mean b3 is perfectly okay but what you
really do it every single game I don't
know I wouldn't okay yeah I played aged
five in a recent game and I felt I can
do this again but I started with age
five and that and that other game which
now this is this time I didn't okay I'm
just developing here and see what
happens but it's not totally clear to me
as what he tries to do here with his
King probably probably this probably
this I'm also going to cancel long play
in a more solid fashion here
yeah trying to ask him what his ideas
maybe some g5 opening up the bishop I
always have a hard time to to imagine
what white wants to do I mean I've got
more space I've got the pair of Bishops
I'm centralized I've got g5g for coming
up and White has what exactly I don't
know probably a some pawn structure but
I don't really see it night a 45-minute
I think it really wants me to play Queen
e7 and then play see five that the
extent of whites plans here maybe yeah
what am i doing the og5 chief form yeah
we can I can prepare that okay let's
let's do this I know I'm weakening f6 so
maybe there is some some tactical idea
some d5 but I go c5 I don't don't really
feel this is any dangerous what is the
point
yeah you know I could this is miss night
for example on e2a control D for f4 g3
knight on c3 I control simply everything
what he what he looks at and I don't I
don't get this type of opening so here
what does he want to do I mean in he has
to do you need to have some kind of idea
before probably he probably wants to
play before yeah right but yeah I just
think I can just take it if I want there
is really nothing going on you go see if
I may go Bishop e5 that never never
works
yeah night therefore I would take the
night I would take it with the pawn I
yes yeah I simply don't get what white
is doing here c5 I just got Bishop e5
what exactly is the point this one okay
okay so we should be five looks
completely normally and let's centralize
this okay I cannot just this is actually
an idea just go c6 in this position mmm
that's an interesting idea let's try
that I mean he wants to go d6 but I
check and take f2 when check is falling
apart completely what is your idea here
I don't even see how he comes III with a
good move this one okay do I just go
back on I have to I mean I don't know I
should not allow him to to win my queen
so you know probably just back to have
six okay so a 5f4 is he threatening to
take here I don't I don't think so Joe
as said and the Chad White is probably
busted but it is a somewhat it is a
slightly murky position due to my king
here on be eight with the night maybe
coming to be six his king isn't exactly
safe either but it is yeah it is still
slightly slightly trickier I guess
especially if I'm playing some crap
which I shouldn't of course but let's
see so let's try to get two pesos FYI
take em less the King is on the third
ring in general the bishop only five is
fantastically strong
that's a fantastic piece CMAs taped
simultaneously being active on both
sides of the board
now it's too late already too late for
any any decent come to play okay so
maybe here white forfeits on time yeah
and those pawns just just go and promote
yeah I know I think white is really
having a hard time after this move here
I know I don't get why you would have
that once you have that every single
white game I think white is really not
equal anymore that's okay
we can play that again and again and
again you know I really believe that
black is very okay yeah and in fact I
would I would rather play c4 instead of
Bishop b5 I think this is quite
interesting at least it's in Sicilian
reversed okay I've got a new game
request out one thing I have to say like
right away that usually I'm going to
make another 60 minute show out of this
but more like a 70 minute show a match
and to play like one final game or so
when we're already over time I won't do
that today I'm trying to finish right on
time because the next show is right
after me like at in 35 36 minutes
because of that time change things are a
little bit off so it's did funny that I
played 65 games now against whole game
and we had exactly one draw like 1-1 is
really really not much one amazing
game started I mean you're often yeah
yeah if like king against king and so on
yeah like no no nothing on the board
okay be Herod I'm going to play the
Scottish war Knights super-solid the
school against Haga is 46 wins 18 losses
one draw and it kind of feels like I
have black every single game but it's
it's not the case it seems I don't see
the white and black score though okay so
let's see what to be Herod is going to
do after age three which is not a very
force to move quite obviously four
signals there are quite some options
rook e8 c 6 would be 8 most of the time
black ball place is 6 anyhow because it
just makes sense to lend some protection
to the pawn however there are ideas that
are a bit more maybe enterprising where
black tries to play rook b8 but should
be 7 and then maybe even c5 a bit
surprised that the black is taking so
much time yeah this is like the most
normal position ever
and why not the regular scotch
or the Scotch gambit less solid yeah the
Scotch gambit is as far as I think as
far as I know just not great right I
mean black is fine in various ways the
regular scotch is fine of course it's
just I'm it's not what I studied yeah
compiling an e4 repertoire went form for
this M which is with almost like every
opening show us almost you can debate
yeah it's just what I felt is a good
idea to to to study because it's easy to
learn
yeah b3 a bit B to pawn was attacked
interesting how he plays this year okay
maybe I can go to a for so that because
he five is currently not protected it
would be neat to get something in like
we never for 2d for and then keep a
blockade over c5 if this would be nice
white what white is trying to do in this
opening in general is simply to claim
that you have a have the slightly better
structure why do I actually run into
before
that was stupid move I mean look before
I probably can just go to detune
interesting I might donate c5 right or
am i screwing things are badly it looks
a little bit fancy this move but I think
it works
yeah it works
Quincy five I take the rook and twenty
four next okay so it's two before before
before I blunder I came but this is now
nice yeah I've got this night now
anchored okay
interesting I did not expect this movie
No so okay I probably have to take I
don't really see a clear alternative to
that
a four maybe no I have to cover it first
but I can do c3m try to keep this option
of a four a five open I have three
against two on the queenside here so I
have got some chances to maybe simply
use that majority you go a four here or
not not sure but in general I think I
should do this Bishop c6 are aware I
mean that cannot be terrible for black
from bubbling oh do I have a tactic no
oh what what the heck that didn't I
don't think that was necessary really
and they have some doubts that it is
that it is good you know
and Bishop c6 hmm now probably this is
better try to get the apron yeah yeah
that's better now if he moves the bishop
I take a 5a route before I was Bishop c6
still still not super easy I think okay
let's check lack resigned they just
resigned him it feels a bit early I mean
I should win this technically speaking
it's it's an exchange but it's so it's
still not so easy I like you blunder one
of the C pawns or so you can easily just
have a draw okay so that was an
unexpectedly quick win out of this
opening yeah I think the Scorch for
Knights is an excellent opening to have
a new repertoire I mean not probably to
play it every single game but it's a
really nice of opening that you can
always play if you just want something
simple and solid
to play there are definitely times for
that yeah when you think okay let's not
do anything fancy let's just play very
sound and solid and oftentimes you can
still win because well black is not it's
not that easy to play black in this
opening there are some some nuances that
are tough too tough to understand and
yeah it's not like black has a guarantee
draw and if if they try to win ooh
difficult that's very difficult it's
it's an open that you quite quite often
actually see it in situations where the
white player is not minding to draw or
that much not like you're playing for a
draw but you play with the draw in hand
yeah I've got two requests out but don't
get paired there are some interesting
players on most Kalinka for example it
would be interesting game started
play dead okay I am play dead
do we have a name for this person James
sit down check him so let's go for the
Bishop b5 check line in the Moscow
variation activate yo and deform this is
quite often looking a lot a lot like
like a wood or pass now not so much that
black has played with a 6 an interesting
question is should I go a 5 or not I
think I'm doing this now but it's it's
it's an interesting question I had
almost the same position in any game not
go and I wasn't really sure if I was a
good idea or not I'm going for it now
how about the cow can caro-kann as black
yeah you'd like to know my opinion if I
think it's a good opening on it yeah it
is good
it's absolutely funny the Kuro is one of
those opening set as the diplay
sometimes I mean not on a regular basis
but sometimes
Paul Whitfield has any suggestion on how
to memorize all these opening lines it's
I think everybody is different they're
some people for some people it's easier
to to memorize things and for some it is
more more difficult he's good night
before right this is why he is taking
all this time I played that badly you
know mm that's terrible my Bishop h6 was
an absolutely terrible move yeah
[Music]
Jan busted basically that was silly
instead of this Bishop h6 nonsense I
should have just played probably maybe
I'm not busted actually I should have
just played the Queen again they're two
G for something I think then White's
position looks quite okay yeah I mean I
think I'm not busted I just counted and
it's it's it's not so terrible
material-wise I'm equal but I'm not
better or anything remotely even but
just like I think I was better if I
don't if I don't do this my Queen might
might be trapped that that that could
work that could happen but how does he
do it I don't know when it's gonna be
him and then he goes c4 actually hmm
why don't I just go a for came he
doesn't even try hmm yeah so how to
learn the lines I'm sorry I had to
somehow I had to look at the game yes I
would whatever I often did basically was
not so much look at things on a move by
move basis but rather play through the
games I mean I tried to find if I felt
okay a certain opening is interesting
for me I often just would try to find
out who is an expert in the opening in
this particular opening and then I tried
to look through their games and try to
understand what was going on this is
what helped me quite a bit it's also
more interesting
then just looking at moves and yeah and
have it disconnected from the games that
same I'm also usually advocating to play
play main lines I mean you don't have to
play like the super main line now every
time but I think it makes sense to to do
something that is reasonably mainstream
because it is things are mainstream the
main line for a reason yeah and my
position here just totally sucks it's
absolutely terrible I'm clearly worse
and they have zero come on a plane a
four was such a terrible move was
absolutely absolutely bad I'm just I'm
just lost him and he has various ways to
do it route b5 for example as a strong
move but it's not the only one no it's
just completely dead right it so let the
game that I absolutely hate him giving
the giving of the point it was just such
a simple point yeah he did not have to
do anything here
it's more or less busted maybe I can
somehow play b3 and trade c4 b porn
Jim no but it's it's it's pretty
terrible at least he's taking some time
a false bad really a bad move
why isn't he moving he is not no he's
still connected and I think I was quite
okay here when I don't go away for Black
is more comfortable but no I shouldn't
be in such a bad shape but something is
wrong am I the one with the problem here
No
yeah I still have those games by Raja
Schwarz away I'm simply crushed crushed
by a strong GM they are they are strong
sometimes I not still look when really
in the second league roughly roughly
what is that like one and one and a half
years ago and he just simply killed me I
mean check and I really recognized
during the game okay
I'm not really on the same kind of level
yeah Graff offered Jim timing Ultron he
offered me a draw but just yeah well
he's just a pawn up I don't know way
somehow he took a long time and some
moves to go maybe something happened
they have doorbell ring us you never
know yeah sometimes you really get get
out played but it I don't know it's it's
a bit different I think for for every
for every player how that might look
yeah that being outplayed in this game
that I had against when video game the
under started understood the whole
situation a lot better really a lot
better and I am it's that person Vitaly
Civic never and I mean I rarely get out
played in the opening completely because
I usually know my stuff quite well even
against 2600 it doesn't really happen
all that much with other players it
might it might be that day that they
even get to get get problems right in
the opening
okay so here what's going on here yeah
that's a complicated way of playing it
and you do this I really don't remember
it's been it's been a while since I
looked at this I mean been a while
sounds like it's been like two years no
it's not but I have not refreshed my
memory there okay that's good just going
g5 maybe and stuff but okay the night is
not badly placed on you three still this
is it seems good for black yeah that
that cannot be the way to do things in
this opening I wonder if there is it
does he have like d5 with Bishop g4
things coming hmm
man the idea one I should have thought
about 91 but that was not necessary move
at all absolutely not
Bishop g4 I can take f6 so this is not a
problem I think so that was entirely
unnecessary interesting takes with the
Queen okay
okay 93 I cannot play what I can do this
and this is a strong Bishop so let's try
to get rid of it this is this is this
position here is a good example why this
is tough to beat opening the white pawn
structure is just so sound you don't
really yeah you sometimes have a hard
time with black to find some some some
some way forward at all okay if I go c3
c4 back row 93 should be okay
so 93 wants to go deform okay so this
one maybe not entirely sure about all
this I'd like to have like a tempo 93 or
so just like one more tempo okay now
equals default and what's the deal okay
yeah my night only one now that is not
good that's not a good piece
yeah but how bad is it really I mean
I've got rookie for maybe Ruby one
rookie for maybe then 93 okay
hmm okay I think I'm pretty much have to
take it I can go get a 1o said helping
me
no probably not
trying to play against the deep on
[Music]
I don't know it should be okay
it should be okay so go back here and
then try to maybe I can even do
something against the April probably not
yeah in being better word okay okay
George is asking any new video lessons
coming from me um do you mean like oh
wait I have to check this here he's
attacking b5 hmm I probably should have
had discovered
check I should have covered this not
good the first ring would have been a
bit easy 'm okay check okay Bishop c4 is
his idea so let's keep that covered now
currently there is nothing planned in
particular like the 33 chess concepts or
so that I've done for EM for the eyes to
see there's nothing like that in the
works
so yeah this should be a draw quite
clearly but still have to play it out
so the ship c4 again time warning
covering that huh isn't that a self pin
and he went into a self pin
that that is okay now I can I know it's
it's a it's a draw draw offered game
drawn yeah I'm okay with the draw here
really yeah I'm working on things but
it's not a video series that it is
planned I'm just working on things and
see what happens you know there could be
a book made out of it or yeah videos we
don't know I don't know so um we have
like eight minutes left so I think one
day the minute start is in order
playing quickly so we wouldn't be too
much influencing the starting time of
the show behind me yeah play dead
I played played him before not not
really sure what game that was to be
honest yeah we somehow play a brain but
I might Tempe down yes I think maybe he
went to see to in one move and he didn't
play Age 3
mm-hmm but he played deep no I played d3
d4 however yeah probably h3 will be
played in the near future
it is a it's a it's quite a useful move
yeah in the brayer you sometimes what
you get is you get a feel into a kind of
position like in the fleet or defense
the only thing in the three doors wide
gets to play a for when the Orlan
prevents b5 but here b5 is on the board
yeah that's almost exactly exactly the
position that I had on the board against
chess legend blasting will hoard earlier
this year
let's see g6 Bishop g7 is what is on the
agenda on the agenda next yeah I'm
playing quickly not to completely bust
the time situation that I will play
anyway
yeah almost almost anyway age six is
normally useful yeah bye bye - good
Cera's in the jet one thing I know where
time was I'm I'm I'm okay it seems that
he wants to place you for this is indeed
a point but I could take before then
okay hmm yeah there is there are
positions where black might even play d5
in general I find this is difficult to
play because you have such flexible pawn
structure you can can do many things
let's do this I'm unsure about this move
but the knight might be okay on d7
because the c5 square could be relevant
Yannick figure c4 I take I can go to c5
these kind of things but the Knight has
a good position on e6 this is where I'm
I'm heading see going c4 now hmm yeah
this is something that I wondered
because my bishop on g7 is not really
helping here all that much I can't evade
it would allow to play before I don't
like to take on C forward maybe I have
to do this
I don't know
Jim
yeah do I take or not I mean I don't
like to take quite clearly but b5 is
also hanging him that's also hanging
[Music]
yeah night is six maybe he can really
take with the Queen that looks a bit
weird but maybe he can maybe prepare
this 496 tough position and he he I'm
not even much ahead on the clock that is
that's really crazy I was ahead like a
mile by a mile
no wait okay but I think he played as
well not sure how how much was I am here
but I'm definitely worse
that's not as I expected
okay 96 prevented so then this one has
to go via e6 to deform and now he's
again burning time
just philosophers what is wrong with the
thinking process of most lower rated
players hmm I don't I don't think
there's a particular thing yeah like one
thing that applies to him to every
single player I don't think this happens
but there are definitely some things one
one thing that is very very obvious
often times as the lack of prophylactic
or thinking you know simply focusing
more on possible play of the opponent
like what is the opponent really trying
to do check this is what they sometimes
don't think about it all really they
they mostly know like a single idea that
they want to play may be related to the
opening or something that they feel they
they know and they simply do that not
really taking into account specifics of
the position for example like they want
to play I know let's say a stone wall
structure because they learnt it at one
time and they played like every single
game even in situations where it just
doesn't work and they don't adjust all
that much a stronger player is usually
more open white to more effects on time
to specific things that that go on okay
so I'm just in time so I'm not stopping
the punctual start of the show after me
thanks for watching guys I'll be back
next Monday definitely
same time in European 10:00 p.m. Central
European Time and we will be back to
4:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time for the
u.s. the u.s. because the times are then
in sync again the daylight saving times
over there for both both continents yeah
thanks for watching guys
soon bye-bye
you